(engine starting)
- [Voiceover] I never had money,
so if I wanted anything, I'd
have to build it myself.
I want other people to be able to do that.
My name is Matthew McEntegart,
I own Vaydor Bodykits.
We have a unique design
car that looks like
a million dollars and we produce it so
that the average person can build it
for an affordable price.
The best way to call this is a re-body.
(drilling sound)
You're making a new car
out of an existing car.
We're cutting everything
off and what we're left with
is just bare bones.
The motor, the drive train,
the frame of the car.
So you have all of your dashboard intact,
all of your engine intact, all wiring,
it's just the cosmetics that
have been cut off the car.
My whole life I always
fixed up my own cars,
so then I decided I'm just
gonna design my own car
that I can call my own, it
doesn't look like anything else.
I'm extremely excited that
a car that I designed,
the Vaydor, is gonna be used
in the Suicide Squad movie.
I had built a car for a customer
on the other coast of Florida.
While it was there the
production company walked in
and they said that's great, it's perfect,
you know, it looks like a million dollars
and nobody's seen it before.
I think that it ties in to Suicide Squad
because it's threatening
when it drives down the road,
it's an angular, open-mouth, angry car.
Seeing my own design on the big screen
is really exciting to me.
The easiest way to put it
is, it's a lottery ticket.
I wanted to design a super car.
I can't draw, I have no design experience,
so I've just shaped it out of foam.
And it took me a year and
a half, seven days a week
before I had a car out of the mold.
I literally had nothing
when I finished this.
Whatever money I had went
into developing this.
It was pretty much the
biggest chance I've ever taken
and this one just, it’s,
people love the car.
It couldn't have worked out better.
(upbeat music)